de l'Ukraine par la Russie une guerre
que la communauté internationale n'a pas
su prévenir selon Amnesty dans son
rapport annuel l'ONG s'allume la
réaction immédiate des États occidentaux
face aux conflit sanctions économiques
contre Moscou aide militaire envoyée à
l'Ukraine
amnestymet toutefois en avant la
politique de poids de mesure des
Occidentaux et une différence de
traitement par rapport aux violations
commises ailleurs dans le monde en
Arabie Saoudite en Israël ou encore en
Chine en négligeant les autres crises
on a moins de riz la valeur de ce qui a
été fait en Ukraine et on leur rend le
le dénouement beaucoup plus difficile
dans le dénouement ça devrait être un
engagement universel pour des valeurs et
pour un état de droit qui s'applique
partout à tout le monde l'ONG dresse
également un état des lieux de la
liberté d'expression elle a régressé
pour plus de 80% de la population
mondiale par rapport à 2021 mais aussi
sur la répression sur 156 états analysés
85 ont eu recours illégalement la force
contre des manifestants pacifiques la
France est dans le viseur Amnesty
demande la suppression de certaines
armes utilisées par les forces de
l'ordre il y a un recours
disproportionné à la France que nous
avons dénoncé que nous avions déjà
dénoncé au moment des gilets jaunes mais
on voit les résultats rien n'a
véritablement changé et il y a toujours
un recours excessif en France
à la violence des de la part des forces
de l'ordre autre thématique ou la
communauté internationale a échoué selon
Amnesty la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique ou encore le droit des femmes
l'ONG rappelle qu'au Mexique par exemple
au moins 3450 femmes ont été tuées en